The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, so this
is the second, last lecture
on trusses.
Then we've got a
holiday on Monday.
And then after that
we'll be into Chapter 3.
I thought I'd write down just
in case it's any use to you,
the four problems that
I intend to include
with the next homework.
That won't be due for quite
a while, a week from Monday.
So these will be the
problems on trusses
that come from particular
trusses drawn in the book.
And then there'll be some
problems from the new material,
that we do next week.
So trusses and really, there's
two main jobs for today.
One is to identify
this matrix A,
the strain-displacement matrix
or the stretching matrix.
How far do the bars stretch?
Everybody remembers A is
going to come in this step.
If we have displacements,
then, of the nodes like,
this would be like a u_1, this
would be a u_1^H and a u_1^V,
this would be a
u_2^H and a u_2^V,
so there are four movements
of the ends of the truss
and of one particular bar, and
then we'll stretch that bar.
And the question, is how much?
So that will be one row of
A. So if we follow one bar,
you remember in the
matrix A, there's
going to be a row for every bar.
So a row for each, row
of A. For each bar.
And if we track down
one of those rows,
we'll have the idea.
And then of course
at the end we'd
maybe be constructing A
without, sort of a free-free A.
And then at the end,
any fixed displacements
that will knock out columns
of A. So that's one job.
And then to see,
so the A is going
to be a little more messy.
It's because we're
in two dimensions.
So compared to the
network problems, and
and the line of springs,
now we have more happening.
We've got more columns
because every node has now two
unknowns.
A horizontal and vertical.
So A is kind of bigger.
And therefore A transpose
C A, you might think,
it's going to be hard
to see what's going on.
But you'll see the
right way to look
at A transpose C A
is a bar at a time.
That's the nice fact
about A transpose C A,
I might focus on that first.
And then comes the fun part.
I'll draw some more
trusses, that may or may not
have mechanisms.
They may or may not be stable.
And we can try to
identify the mechanisms.
Actually, as before.
We'll do it by
engineering instinct
rather than by solving.
I mean, in principle, we
could always use elimination.
Or ask MATLAB or any
other system to do it,
and look for the
solutions to Au=0.
And decide are the
columns of A independent.
In that case the
truss is stable.
This matrix is
invertible, we know
all the good possibilities.
And then there's the more
interesting possibility,
of having some
solutions to that.
In which case that
matrix will be singular.
There'll be some modes
in our big system
that will cause it to fail.
But it's kind of
fun to find those.
OK, while I've written
A transpose C A,
may I remind you about a good
way to do that multiplication.
OK, so imagine I'm
just putting a number.
Here's going to be the
matrix A. So the matrix A
will have a bunch of rows,
row one, row two, so on.
These rows will correspond
to bar one, bar two, and bar
three.
OK.
OK, then we have C, so
that's a square matrix.
That each bar has a spring
constant, so c_1, c_2, c_3,
and then we have A transpose.
And those rows, or
columns of A transpose.
So that's the sort of
picture of A transpose C A,
for a three-bar,
three bars only.
But the point is
made right here.
There's a row of
A for every bar.
Right?
Because our matrix A is m by n.
If there are m bars, a
row for every bar, and it
tells us how far that
bar is stretched.
And we'll figure out
what its entries are.
That's our main job.
I'm just looking ahead.
Suppose we've got that row.
And that row, and that row.
So a row for every bar.
Now, here I've taken three bars.
Now, how do I multiply
those matrices?
Well, I can do it
different ways.
But here's a cool way to do it.
Just-- The way I want to
point out is column times row.
If you multiply matrices you're
allowed to-- The effective c_1,
c_2, c_3, is going
to be very simple.
So I'm really paying
attention here
to A transpose A. If I want
to multiply A transpose A,
I can do row times column
as usual and get one number.
Or I can do column times row
and get a whole little matrix.
And that's the bar one matrix.
It's the element
matrix, and that's
how finite elements
will be assembled,
and that's why I should
keep mentioning this point.
So the way to do
that column times
row thing, and then of course
that c_1 just multiplies
that row, that'll be c_1.
Row one, transpose, that's
the column, times row one.
That's what's
coming from bar one.
That column multiplies
the c_1 and that row.
You see how nice, that's the
element matrix associated
with the first bar.
And then there'll be a
second column times the c_2,
times the second row.
So plus c_2, row two
transpose, row two.
That's a matrix again.
Plus c_3, row three
transpose, row three.
I focus on that because you
don't think of this as a way
to multiply matrices, but it's
really a nice thing to notice.
And it's better to
notice it now when
we have three bars or something,
than in a big finite element
code.
Yeah.
So this is, just if I complete
it, complete this thought,
this I would call
a one bar matrix.
That's the matrix A transpose
A if there's only one bar.
Actually, one of the problems
at the end of this section
is find the element
matrix for one bar.
And I guess it's
about what we're
going to get to when
we do that one bar.
Do you remember
what it was in the,
just to connect
this thought, what
was the little matrix
in the case of networks?
So in the case of
networks, there
was just one unknown
for each, not two.
So for networks, just, I'm
just going to put down the,
and you'll recognize
it immediately.
The little element matrix
was the c for that,
and there was a
[1, -1; -1, 1] what?
Do you remember that guy that
was the [-1, 1] from a row?
[-1, 1] from a column?
So this was exactly
c times the [-1, 1]
from the column times the
[-1,  1] from the row.
That's where this simple
little matrix came from.
And you remember
that the, so what's
involved in creating
this big A transpose
C A is just create all
these little pieces, which
are like this, but they're
going to be a little bigger.
In fact, in a minute
I'm going to ask you
what size they'll be.
Well, they're
really big matrices.
There are a whole lot of zeroes
there that I didn't even put.
Zeroes are there for rows
and columns that aren't
touching this particular edge.
And again, this matrix.
There'll be all
kinds of zeroes in A.
Because a typical
row of A, bar one,
is going to have non-zeroes only
for the, yeah what's the size?
How many non-zeroes
in a typical row of A?
Getting the count right first
is like half the battle.
How many non-zeroes
in a typical row of A?
This was the network case
where we had a couple of nodes.
And they were connected.
And we had an
unknown at each end.
So two unknowns were involved.
The little matrix
was two by two.
It properly has lots of zeroes
for all the other nodes that
are not involved.
And then that matrix
kind of gets, assembled
is the word I
think usually used.
All these little guys
get assembled, you
know, pasted, stamped, I hear
as the verb sometimes now.
Take these little matrices
for this little element.
And stamp them into the big A
transpose C A. This is the c_1,
so this gives the
c_1's in the matrix.
And the c_2's and the c_3's.
Alright.
Now, just before we-- I'm
like doing this preliminary,
before I write down
anything, the exact row.
What's the size of, for
trusses, how many non-zeroes
in a row of A?
So that's my question.
How many non-zeroes in a
typical row, like for that bar,
non-zeroes in a row of A?
So A is the matrix that tells
us how much, that row of A
is the row that tells us how
much this bar stretched when
this moved along by u H
1, and up by you u V 1,
and this moved along by
say, u H 2, and up by u V 2.
Well, I've written all those in.
So that you can
tell me this number.
How many?
What's your guess?
When I tell you,
you'll say of course.
How many u's are involved in
the stretching of that bar?
Four.
Exactly.
Instead of one at each end,
we have two at each end.
So the answer is four.
How many, the answer is four.
And now the only remaining
question is, what are they?
What are those four numbers?
The four non-zeroes in the row?
So let me just answer that.
They are, so here is that row.
So we the two non-zeroes
associated with it.
Well, the way I've numbered
these nodes one and two--
Since I've numbered
them one and two,
the non-zeroes are going
to come right at the start.
And then a whole
lot, then this is all
going to be zero after that.
Because those will be nodes
three, four, or five, whatever,
that don't involve bar one.
So bar one just connects
node one to node two.
Now, what do you think?
Well, let me put in
the key quantity here.
This bar is at an angle.
It's at an angle theta.
So there's a theta.
Angle theta.
OK.
And so that angle is going
to enter these things.
In fact, here's what you get.
You get, I think if I put the
one up there and the two down
there, let's see.
What am I thinking now?
I'm saying if u 1 H
is positive, that's
going to stretch the bar.
That's a positive stretching.
So I'm expecting a
positive u 1 H to give me,
I'm expecting that sort of
to come in with a plus sign.
Now suppose the
bar is horizontal.
Suppose the bar is
horizontal, then
how much does the
u 1 H stretch it?
It stretches it by the
whole u 1 H, right?
If the bar was horizontal,
so theta equals zero.
I'm just doing these, we got
to sort out this theta angle
stuff.
So here's my thing.
If the bar happens
to be horizontal,
then that stretching by
u H 1, will completely
stretch the bar.
If the bar happened
to be-- Yeah yeah.
And of course, this way.
So that for a horizontal bar,
I'll just be back to this step.
I'll have a one and a minus
one. u-- Oh yeah, remind me
about that.
Why doesn't u vertical, for
a horizontal bar like this,
why does this one
not stretch the bar?
You remember that
from last time,
that was the little bit of
trig that we did when we forced
ourselves to stay linear.
So we dropped the second
order correction, that
would come from going this way.
Right?
I mean you must have
noticed, like walking?
Suppose you want to walk from
here to the end of the bar, OK?
Well, if somebody moves
the end of the bar forward,
you have to take
those extra steps.
The bar really stretches.
But, if somebody moves
the bar this way,
then the extra bit of
length is much less.
In fact, it's zero
to first order.
This is like taking
shortcuts when
you walk across the courtyard.
So when the angle's
theta, I'm only
expecting a one and a minus one.
On the horizontal.
And zeroes on the vertical.
OK, now I'm ready
to write it in.
I think when the angle's
theta, when the angle's theta,
any theta, that was
when the angle was zero,
I think we get a cos theta.
Doesn't your instinct
say that this
is on the u_1, u horizontal 1.
And then the u vertical 1,
tell me what these should be.
And then we'll make,
what do you suppose
is the entry, second non-zero,
the one that corresponds
to a vertical movement.
Here it would be,
for a horizontal bar
when theta is zero, I'm
going to see a zero there.
But if the bar is at
an angle like this,
what am I going to see?
Everybody's going
to get it right?
What do I put in there?
Sine theta.
What else could it be?
Right, OK, sin(theta).
And now what about the next
guy, the other end of the bar?
u H 2 and u V 2, those are
the other two non-zeroes.
What your guess
for u 2 H, u H 2?
If I move this forward,
what's the change
in length of the bar?
What would your guess
be that goes into there?
Say it again?
-cos(theta).
-cos(theta), right, yeah.
The movement of
the other end, like
if I move this guy a
little bit to this side.
That will shorten the bar.
Forget about that one.
If I move this over,
the bar becomes shorter.
And the cosine tells me
the key number there,
how much it becomes shorter.
If the bar was horizontal,
the cos(theta) was one,
it counts a hundred percent.
If the bar is vertical,
and I move it horizontally,
it comes zero percent.
Because the linearity says
there was no first order change.
And now tell me the
final non-zero entry.
And I see I didn't leave
much room for all the zeroes.
OK, what's the u 2 V entry?
-sin(theta), of course.
And then come all the zeroes,
for whatever other joints
are not involved with bar one.
So let me, maybe to
make this picture best,
I should move that over
to where it belongs.
Now, if I add up along a bar,
add up the four numbers there,
what do I get?
Zero.
You expected that, right?
In fact, if I add just
that and that I get zero.
If I add that and
that I get zero.
Just the way I got zero here.
In the incidence matrices.
The column of all ones is
certainly going to solve Au=0.
Unless the supports
remove those, of course.
If the supports
don't allow all ones
because some have
to stay at zero,
then I could have
a stable truss.
OK, that's a typical bar.
A typical row.
That's a typical row.
OK, and now maybe while I'm
on the same subject, what
is the size, what does
this thing look like now?
This is in A. This
is in the matrix A,
and now I want to
ask you before I even
come back to all this stuff,
what about in A transpose A?
In A transpose A, A transpose
C A, it the whole deal.
The element for-- The little
matrix, the element matrix,
can I call it that?
Or the one-bar matrix,
call it the one-bar matrix.
Will be, is what?
So I want this, it would
be typical-- c_1, row one
transpose, row one,
that's the typical guy.
And how many non-zeroes in that?
Multiplying a row.
Sorry, multiplying
a column that has
four non-zeroes
times a row that has
four non-zeroes times a
number, which is just fine.
How many non-zeroes are
going to sit in this element
matrix, this one-bar matrix?
16.
16 non-zeroes.
And they're going to be, I have
cosine, sine, minus cosine,
minus sine, multiplying cosine,
sine, minus cosine, minus sine.
And all multiplied by c_1.
So that's the matrix.
And you see what it looks
like. c squared, cs, so on.
16 guys.
So we have four squared as our
element matrix, where here we
had two squared.
And in finite elements,
when you get to elasticity,
and you've got triangles,
you've got triangular elements,
then there are three
nodes involved.
So you're up to higher numbers.
But this gives you the idea.
And remember that this four
by four, the way I've done it,
the way I've numbered
it, one, two,
happens to sit up in
the upper left corner.
Of A transpose C A. But
can you sort of imagine
how the code would be written?
The code would be
written, take each bar,
and what do I have to
know about the bar?
Just imagine a code
that would do trusses.
Actually, the final
problem that I'm not
assigning in this section says
what would the code be like?
Can we just have a think
about what the code would look
like if we were to write it.
What would the input have to be?
For each bar, what
input do I need?
For this bar, I need to know--
And for the whole truss.
What do I have to tell,
what's the information that I
need for the whole truss?
I have to know the positions
of all of the joints, right?
So I'd have to know the
coordinates of that, (x, y),
the coordinates of this one,
(x_1, y_1) for joint one,
(x_2, y_2).
So I'd have to have a little
list of what would that be?
m by two?
Oh, no.
N. N by 2.
I have N, what do I have now?
Think of what
information do I have
to report about this truss?
I guess I have N,
capital N, joints.
And I need two coordinates,
x, y for each position.
So that's N by 2, this.
OK, and then for every bar,
what do I need to tell it?
What do I need to put in
the code for a typical bar?
I certainly have to put
in the c for that bar.
And what else do I need to know?
I need to know which
joints it's connected.
Right?
I have to tell the system
that this bar is between two
and one, one and two.
I have to tell it which pair.
So I guess I have a list
of m bars, and for each bar
I must tell the system
the two node numbers,
and the c, the stiffness.
The constant for Hooke's Law.
Right, do you see this picture?
Just sort of visualizing,
creating a code here.
And then the code
would do all this,
oh, have I given enough
information to find theta?
Or do I have to
import theta also?
No.
I told you the
positions, so it'll
figure out cos(theta)
theta and sin(theta).
It actually won't
figure out theta,
that's always a
dumb thing to do,
find the actual
angle. cos(theta)
and sin(theta) is the
quantities we want.
So given that position, (x, y),
and this position (x_2, y_2),
it would know cos(theta)
and sin(theta).
And having drawn
his picture allows
me to make once
more the key point
about small displacements.
What's the angle of the
bar after it's moved?
After it's displaced?
It was theta before
it was displaced,
and the angle after is theta.
To first order, the
angle doesn't change.
Because these are little
tiny movements of the ends.
I've drawn them much bigger
than they should be drawn.
They're little, tiny
movements of the ends
so that the angle is not
significantly changed.
Otherwise we're into
geometric nonlinearity
and that stuff, that makes
the problem much, much harder.
OK, are you seeing
sort of the picture?
I guess what I
haven't completely--
I've really depended
more on your intuition
than on a calculation to
say that these are the four
non-zeroes.
What did I ask you to do?
I asked you to check that that
was right in the extreme cases,
like if theta is zero,
the bar is horizontal,
then we just have a 1, 0, -1,
0; vertical isn't happening.
If the bar is vertical so that
the angle is 90 degrees then
we would have a 0, 1, 0,
-1; everything's vertical.
And the book draws
a little picture,
and computes delta l from
these four small movements.
And takes the leading
term and sure enough it
produces that row of the matrix.
Gosh, I talk real fast.
But do you think you could
now create the stiffness?
If you had a real truss, you
could create the matrix A
for it?
C is simple, it's given to you.
You could create
A transpose C A?
You might just want to
write the command as A'
* C * A or something.
And let MATLAB do the thinking.
But I wanted to
just see what these,
how this four by four piece
appears in this product,
from each bar.
The 16 non-zeroes will
appear in different positions
and you told the code
what those positions are.
You had to give the code
a local-to-global picture.
This is the local picture.
Watch one bar.
Then it has to fit in
this big n by n matrix,
and that means you
have to know what
joints was that bar connecting.
So which positions do these
16 non-zeroes assemble into?
That's some time
devoted to a job
that I actually don't
plan to require you to do.
Creating this truss problem.
What I think is kind of more
fun and that's, these homework
problems would deal with it,
is part two of the lecture.
Going back to
mechanisms, and now
thinking about more
complicated trusses.
We now in principle could
find the solutions to Au=0
because we now
have constructed A,
and we could get MATLAB to do
the work or Python or whoever.
But can I go to part
two now and draw a truss
and ask you about
the mechanisms?
Let's see.
I guess somewhere
in the problem set,
but not one of the assigned ones
is-- Start with those six bars.
And six joints, so
these are six joints.
And OK, as it stands, how
many-- That's a good question.
As it stands, what's the
shape of the matrix A?
How many rows has it got?
So as it stands, so
I'll call it A_0,
for no supports have been added.
A_0, just the full matrix.
Is what shape?
6 by 12.
Good.
Is 6 by 12.
OK, of course it's not stable.
We know that.
We haven't supported anything.
So in a typical case,
how many solutions to A,
so I'm going to ask you
how many solutions to Au=0?
And what's your guess?
Six.
Got six equations,
we've got 12 u's, 12-6,
so this is going to be 12-6.
And of course six
solutions to that equation.
It's what I would expect.
There could be, it
could be possible
that the six equations
are not independent.
If they really dropped
to five then this
would bump up to seven, I don't
think it's going to happen.
Now, can you describe those
six solutions, not with
numbers, just with, tell me.
I hope you can, because
I can't right now.
OK, three of them we know.
So with no supports at all,
what are three rigid motions?
And what are they?
The whole truss could move to
the right, the whole hexagon.
It could all move up, it could
all rotate about one point.
All three of those would
be movements, displacements
that don't stretch anything.
OK, three rigid motions.
Across, up, and rotate.
OK, and I can get rid of those
by supporting some nodes.
But let me see, I don't
know what's going to happen.
When I describe this topic
as the fun one in 18.085,
it's more fun for
you than for me.
Because I draw something like
that and I start worrying can
I think of three-- How many
mechanisms to look for?
Three.
That's a big number.
I bet you I can find one but
you guys have got to, alright,
tell me some mechanisms.
Let me try to draw them.
What would be one mechanism?
Collapses, yeah, somehow.
How shall I make it collapse?
Can squeeze in, yeah,
maybe that's the first one.
This guy comes in, this
guy, what does that do?
I've got 15 minutes here, I
could pull that board down
and draw another one.
What is this one here?
Let's see, if that comes in, do
these guys have to go up a bit?
Yeah, because that
angle's not 90 degrees.
So we've got a first
order change in this.
So this comes in a little,
this goes up a little,
this guy maybe stays straight.
Would you go for this,
I mean, please say yes?
Something happens there, right?
These things go in
and those go out.
Could you create
the-- I mean if this
was a equal-side,
regular hexagon,
you could put in all
the numbers for all 12,
I would be looking
for 12 numbers.
Six joints and they
each have two u's,
so that wouldn't be so
simple but you could do it.
So that would be one.
Looking for number two.
What would be another one?
So sort of squeezing
in like whatever.
What do you think?
Any others?
Maybe that's possible.
Maybe I just look at it,
you think that would work?
We could hope those
were independent,
but I wouldn't
put my life on it.
I have this squeeze in, this
squeeze in and this squeeze in,
I would worry a little bit.
I can see another one.
AUDIENCE: Half, for--
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Fold it in half.
AUDIENCE: Along, I guess that
sort of gets into 3-D, but.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah, we've
got to stay in the plane,
right.
I have instead of what?
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Squeeze that out.
Yeah.
Good.
Number two.
And then I can see, here's one,
here's an easy one to think of.
Leave these three alone
and just rotate these guys.
Bring this down, right?
Just bring these three
vertically down, or something.
You see why it's sort of, did
you like that one alright?
It seems simple to me, looking
at it, just leave these guys--
Rotation, let this turn down.
This turn down, let's
say, and this go down.
Maybe these would all
drop by the same amount.
Maybe.
So anyway, whatever.
Let's put some supports on them.
And get these numbers down.
So let's support, as
usual, the bottom guy.
OK, so different problem now.
I won't call that A_0, I'll
call it A. I'll ask myself,
is it stable or unstable?
The matrix is now six by what?
Eight, because
I've taken away, I
have four reaction forces,
two at each support,
horizontal and vertical.
I've got four free nodes.
And six by eight.
Let me put in-- So six by
eight, what am I expecting now?
Any rigid motions?
No, no rigid motions now.
How many solutions
am I expecting?
Two, I think.
Probably two.
How many mechanisms?
Well, no rigid motions.
So probably two mechanisms.
Now, can we find two mechanisms?
Alright, this is
like more reasonable.
We can see whether whether
we get two mechanisms
and whether they're
really different.
OK, what are the mechanisms now?
These guys are fixed.
So forget my little sketch
here, and think again.
What do you see?
Alright, let's
have one mechanism.
What would one mechanism be now?
There have to be two.
What do you think?
Sit on it.
Alright, bring these guys
down, and then these guys
will go out, is that it?
OK, so a number, mechanism
number one, sit on truss.
OK.
Alright.
Now, I don't know
what number two
is, that's why I'm taking time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah.
Or could we do this, could we
bring these guys in and let's
go up?
It's the same thing.
OK, so squeeze truss.
Squeeze sides.
Is that the same
thing that I had,
number one the same as two.
Oh jeez, OK.
Is that what-- Everybody
is agreeing with this?
OK.
So I didn't get, my
number two was no good.
OK.
What's a better number two?
Hold an edge?
Like that one.
I'm just doing what
you say, I'm not.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Just
this guy, rotates like so.
And this guy will
rotate, and this guy.
That looks pretty good to me.
Good, is that correct?
Say that one again?
So the first one was
when these two came down
and these went out.
Right, OK.
And now your suggestion
is, you picked on this guy
and held it fixed.
And then this one came
down a little bit.
It'll, of course,
how will it move?
It will move
perpendicular, right?
Small movement.
The bar is not going
to change length,
that's the whole point, right?
The bar is not changing length.
So the movement must be, it
must be a simple rotation.
Around here.
OK.
Right, and of course
again you might say well,
the bar really did change
length because that's not
quite the same as that.
But then again that's
my second order basis.
So that one came down,
and what did this one do?
Came down the same.
OK, and this one it also moves.
What is that?
OK, so what am I going
to call this one?
Fix one.
Yeah.
Fix one node.
And that makes sense.
Fix one joint, yeah.
And then, and rotate the rest.
I think that would be possible.
Yep.
OK, a small prize
for anybody who,
maybe handwritten, a picture
of two really nice mechanisms.
Somehow this one seems
a little un-symmetric
in a problem that's
so symmetric,
so I would guess that
somewhere along the line
we could find a kind of
more some symmetric one.
But I don't see what
it is right now.
Can the whole thing
rotate a little?
Could that rotate, could
the whole thing rotate?
Yeah, maybe it could.
This guy would go up,
maybe that's possible.
That's somehow got
everybody into the action.
So I'll put "or rotate".
OK, so you see what
questions you get into.
May I just draw a
different truss?
So those homework questions
are other trusses.
Here's one that I drew
in the book itself.
Yeah, may I draw this,
I called it a treehouse.
OK, so I have, so here's one
that's actually in the book.
And it's got a couple of
bars going up, and one over.
So that's the start.
Then it's got a
diagonal and that one.
And then here comes
the treehouse.
OK, right.
Well, just to get, let's
again get the count right.
So what's the matrix
A for this treehouse?
A is how many by how many?
How many bars are
you seeing here?
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, eight bars.
And how many unknown
displacements?
Ten.
We got five joints
that are not supported,
and each one has two unknowns.
So A is eight by ten.
So I expect two mechanisms.
OK, so again I'm looking
for two mechanisms.
OK, what's one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: It's what?
This guy just falls, right.
This looks unfortunately
very much like the treehouses
that I built for my kids.
Well, so linear algebra
sentenced them to fall, right?
OK, that's one.
I probably propped
it up with one more
bar, but of course that
wouldn't be enough,
because it's got two mechanisms,
so if I make it nine by ten
I haven't saved the kids.
OK, with eight by ten,
what's the other mechanisms?
The whole thing could
turn the-- Nothing
preventing turning here.
They can't move but
they could turn.
So the whole thing could go
over, right, the whole thing
could just-- That would be a
horizontal movement of all five
nodes.
The horizontal of
all five nodes.
And again, slightly downwards,
but that's a second order
effect.
OK, so that's the second truss.
OK.
So this is really like
practice for discrete problems,
for the problems of
plane elasticity.
And the point is that there are
two unknowns for each point.
If we have
differential equations.
So the differential
equations of plane
elasticity are
not really simple.
They're not really simple.
And 3-D elasticity even more.
Because the points
are physical points
and they can move three ways,
and it gets quite interesting.
And those are the major problems
of computational mechanics.
OK, let's say, holiday time,
and I'll see you next Wednesday
for Chapter 3.
Which moves to partial
differential equations.